how do you know when you meet your
perfect partner that you think is going
to be with you for life maybe you get
married maybe you don't but my point is
why are they the right one for you you
have to think long term are they your
partner because they understand you
that's the key you'll know it when you
meet somebody that can actually put up
with all your BS but at the same time
let you grow that's the magic if you can
find that person because they have to
understand you the worst thing is if you
actually get together with somebody
that's not anywhere like you in the
terms of having your own goals and your
own desire for a long-term lifestyle so
you want somebody that doesn't outspend
you that understands what your means are
and how you can work together to build
something special like really marriage I
hate to say this but it's a business and
you're joining with a partner and when
it falls apart it's really expensive you
don't want that you know you have the
right one when you think this is going
to work out not only tomorrow but next
month next year and for the rest of my
life